[Music]
from all of us down here in Mission
Control welcome to
space the Russians always knocked three
times I think it's just a
[Applause]
Superstition down to
park listening to
Wind of
Change wow I mean I seen pictures but
this is we don't talk politics here we
are
[Music]
one hey guys wait a minute what the hell
is going on down there oh wa we got to
get off now guys get out oh my
God
you s do you
read War has broken out
below and we were told to take the
ISS by any means necessary if we got
orders from our government to take
control what do you suggest we do now
did you
ever we could be so close the Russians
got the same orders as us and they just
struck first struck
[Music]
first M we're evolved
species
[Music]
oh